そこで実際に目に触れたものにサティできると
実際に耳に触れるものにはサティができるというところで
本当は音は存在しない
バラの花も存在しない
人も建物もそこには存在しないんです
その時は七覚支のサティなんです
で そこまでサティを実践しなくちゃいけないんです
で これサティがそこまで成長するために
それに繋げて必要なものは二番目ダンマ・ヴィッチャーヤなんですね
択法照覚支 この択法照覚支はどのように我々はまずこの初心者が実践するかというと
瞑想経験ない人が で まあそのその別な別なものをやる時も確認する
例えば座って膨らみ縮み見るだけは瞑想じゃなくて
歩くときもそれも確認する
出すときもそれも確認する
食べる時もそれも確認する
料理をしている時でも
それも確認しながらやると
そうするといろんなものを確認しているんですね
それで その人にはこの分別能力つくんです
で 膨らみ縮みと歩くことはまるっきり同一ものやという感じではなくて
そちらの働きは違うんじゃないか
自分が右足上げますということと
お茶飲みますということ
まるっきり同じだよとということではなくて
それいろんなものを確認できることによって
この物事に対する分別能力ついてくるんですね
この分別能力がそうやって生まれてくると
この択法照覚支が成長し始めるということなんですね
ですから 択法照覚支の即的な訳はやっぱり分別能力なんです
分別能力ないと全部ごっちゃ混ぜに一体にして理解する
バラの花目に入っちゃったら
やっぱり花は綺麗なもんだと
すぐもう決めて さらに生きててよかったと
こんな美しいものを感じられて
全部一体にしてごちゃ混ぜにして見てるんですね
例えば択法照覚支ある人にとっては
バラの花は綺麗だということはちょっと決められない
ないんですね それはその時その時見た
見た時の自分のアプローチによるものやと
同じバラの花であろうが
人が見る瞬間のその人の心の働き
それによって綺麗か綺麗じゃないか
すごい綺麗か まあまあ綺麗か
どっちかという風に あるいは面白くないか
どっちかという風に感情が生まれるんだからね
でもそういう分別能力ない人は全部ごっちゃ混ぜにして綺麗と哲学作るんですね
世の中には美しいものがあるんだとかね
そういう風に言えないはずなんで
哲学は成り立たないはずなんです
分別能力あると そこでサティを実践する人は花を見て見えましたと
綺麗に感じた 綺麗に感じた
それは別々に認識するんですね
綺麗に感じた感覚と花は全く別なものだと
だから別なものだから
花に 花の原因で綺麗に感じたかもしれませんけど
だからといって自分の心の中で綺麗に感じることは花のせいやというふうなことでもないんだと
同じ違う瞬間で綺麗に感じない時もありますね
そういう風にこの現象の働き
別々にいろんな働きしているんだと
それぞれの現象が自分の働き持ってる
で そのように理解していかなくちゃいけないんですね
最初は 例えばサティの場合は膨らみ縮みやら歩くことやらやって始まるんだけど
それから普通の分別能力がついてくると
それでサティが本当に私が前説明したようなサティになったならば
現象は消えてエネルギーのレベルで物事を体験できる
その時はこの本当のこの択法照覚支も生まれているんですね
ですから サティが択・覚・捨に分別能力につながるし
いわゆるサティがあると分別能力が生まれるということで
分別能力があるならば
サティもちゃんと働いていると離れません
だから一つ修行すると
まあ必然的に次の覚支が目が覚めてくる
そこでもし目が覚めてこないならば
自分が単なるマンネリになって
もうサティやってるだけになる
そこら辺直さなくちゃいけない
ちょっと択・覚・捨生まれるように
だだやってるんだっていうことだけ
択・覚・捨生まれないならば
それはもうヴィパッサナーというか
この悟りの道に入ってるサティではないんですね
ですから 必然的に択・覚・捨につなげなくちゃいけない
サティの結果として いわゆる分別能力を生まれなくちゃいけない
物事を別々に感じる 例えば食べ物にサティをしたならば
この様々な味は別々に味わえるようになるはずなんですね
普通の人間みたいにいきなり何か口に入れて
あ これは美味しいと なんで美味しいと言うんですか？ということが必要なんです
そこで あ まあこういう味があって
こういう味があって こういう味があるんだ
と この味はものすごく別々に感じられると
で 甘さは甘さで しょっぱさはしょっぱさで
そうやって辛さが辛さでとか
別々に感じられると これも舌の方でサティを実践しているということになっちゃうんですね
そのために必要な情報を仏教で提供している
例えば味は何種類ありますか？と
それは今科学的に研究しても同じ答えを出しているんですからね
舌が何を感じるかというと
塩を感じる 苦い 苦味 苦いということを感じる
それから甘さ感じられる
それからまあ 酸っぱさ感じられる
まあ七種ですね でも それで昔は医学ではね
この舌ではそれ別々な部分で感じるんだと
苦味感じる場所と甘さ感じる場所が違うのでいったのが
そんなことなくて もう舌全体でもう神経広げてるんだから
もう感じることは感じられますけど
でもすごい鋭い人がね
敏感な人が やっぱりこういうこういう味ですよと
とわかるんですね そのためにはやっぱり食べる時はサティを実践しなくちゃいけないんですね
だからとにかくこの それにサティを実践しないと
念覚支にもならないし
択法覚支も生まれてこないんです
で 例えばまあ修行道場とかそういうところで歩く瞑想がかなり時間かけてやってるというところの
ただ左足上げますということだけじゃなくて
この左足を上げたくなる感
上げたくなってくる 上げたくなってくると
足の中でいろんなちょっとした変化が起きてくる
その変化によって足が上げる
それ同時に自分の意志が働いて足を動かしていること
で 足を下ろすと また足にいろいろ変化が起きる
起きたところで まあ即自分の意志
気持ちが変わってしまいます
右足上げた そうすると今まで硬かった右足がもう違う足になっている
そうやって人の気持ちとこの物体の動きと二つ別々に見えてくる
それからその物体も気持ちによって変化しているんだと
例えば左足が硬くなるのは
人の気持ち 体体重移動したんだからでしょうね
それで硬い足になっちゃうし
重い足になっちゃうし
で 右足を上げたいと思った瞬間に
何のことなく右足が軽くなって上げられるぐらい軽いんですね
で そういう風に この人の気持ちによって
その自分の体という物体の生まれる変化
そういうのを明確に発見できるということをところで
人のこの鋭さですね 敏感というかね
感じられる敏感ということがすごい明確になってくるということで
あの択法覚支なんです
で それだけで悟れるかというと
じゃあもう悟ってるはずなんですね
それだけでは悟りじゃないんです
で 択法覚支の中 でもやっぱりこの
まあ物事 いろんなものを組み合わせて現象が生まれることをちゃんと発見できる
それから物事 やっぱり瞬間瞬間変化しなきゃ成り立たないんだと
だから無常有るが故に存在を成り立っているんだと
空が故にじゃないんです
そこら辺 お釈迦さんはすごい厳密にぴったしおっしゃってる
無常があるという 空がある
空有るが故にと言ったならば
ヒンドゥー教となるようになってしまった
今現に我々知っている大丈夫の言葉のようになってしまった
ですから その そこら辺
ところまで 択法覚支を成長すると
まあ悟りの一部になるんですね
あるいはこれが消えるんだからこれが生まれるんだと
これが消えなかったらこれが生まれません
で この智慧が発達するんだったら
ほんのちょっとのヴィパッサナー瞑想でも十分なんです
ちょっと足をちょっと上げて歩いてみただけでもね
左足を下ろしていなかったならば
右足を上げられませんね
それで右足を下ろしたならばこそ
左足を上げるという現象が生まれるんです
だから それぐらいでこの真理発見できれば
まあそんな苦労しなくたって
ほんの瞬間で悟るんです
でも頭が良すぎても 何年かかるかわからないんです
まあ簡単なことで発見できればね
真理は隠れてないんです
だからある現象が消えるんだから
次の現象は生まれますよと言ったら
なんかすごい複雑に感じ考えられますけどね
でもいつでもその真理は目の前にあるんです
電気が死ぬことによって光が生まれるんだから
電気もそのままでやって光も出てくるってことはありえないんです
ご飯が消えることによってお腹が満腹になるんだと
いつでも目の前で一つの現象消えて
次の現象できるっていうことはね
あるはずなんです なんで見えないかっていうことは問題なんです
うんうん 覚覚支はもっと少々わかりやすくするならば
あのナーマとルーパですか
心の働きと物質の働きっていうのは区別できる
これは心 これは体と 手上げる場合は上げたくなるのは心であって
それで上げていると感じることはね
それまた心の働きであって
そのどれぐらい上げてるか
どのように上げてるんですかとか
そこは心がコントロールしている
それで手がそれなりに動いている
そこで物質のエネルギーと精神的な心の動きっていうのは
そうやってうまく合体して離れないようにして
心と体が機能しているんだと
それを分別できない人々は
心と体が一体だよと 魂と体は一体だよとかね
平気なことを言ってますけど
そんなことはなくて 心も体も別々に働いてるんだと
ただ あの不可分な状態で働いてるだけですけど
実質的には違うんだ それでさらに進めてみると
心のみを見る それから体のみを見てみると
それは瞬間瞬間変化しているということ見えてくる
そのように瞑想を進めるなら
進んでいくならば この七支覚支の中に入ります
大体この二つだけでまあ結構終了しますけどね
三番目に出てくるのはヴィリヤ
ヴィリヤ三覚支 ヴィリヤっていうのはこの精進
支覚支ですね 精進すること
それで で 例えば物事見えてくる
分別能力を見えてくると
その人では じゃあもっと頑張ってみようという気持ちが自然に生まれてくるんです
また逆に頑張って頑張って進んでいけないと分別能力も生まれてこないしね
ですから 自然に生まれる時もあります
例えば物事を分別して見えてくると
あ これは面白いと さらにどうなるかと
何物かといって見たく見たくなる
[笑い]そういう人は悟りまで行く
今まで私が知ってる限りはそうじゃなくて
見えてくるとえらく威張るか
自己高慢するか すごい混乱するか
何かちょっと現象とかね
もうはっきりと見えてくる
すごい混乱するか 怖くなるか
どっちかなんですね だから
まあこれ仏道じゃないんだけど
変な 変ではなくて ちょっと違う次元に物事見えたならばね
さらに続けて見るのは普通の人やることなんですけど
何か違うもの発見したんだと
もっとじゃあ掘ってみようと
というのは普通なんですけど
ああ 嫌だ どうしますか？と私に聞くんですね
そうすると私はどんどんどんどん指導したいという気持ちはどんどんどんどん減って減っていっちゃうんです
で やがてストップします
指導しないと だからそういう自然的な現れてくるものだから
こういう心は自然に持ってこないと
もうどうすることもできないんですね
とにかくこの精進というのは努力することで
択覚取で分別能力がついてくると
今経験していないような現象はね
もっともっと基本的なところで見えてくるんだからね
で それに驚くもしないで
これなんだろうと で 進んで
もっと頑張って修行しましょうと
もっと真剣にサティ入れよと
もっときめ細かく 力強くサティを実践しようということに
普通のノーマルな人だったらなる
ですから 二番目から三番目っていうのは自然に進む過程なんです
そこで経典では精進はどのように説明していますかというと
今自分のあのやった悪いこと
やってきた不善をやらない努力と
やったことがない不善を絶対に二度とやらない努力と
これからもやらない努力
自分持っている善を完成し
完成しようという努力と
自分持ってない善をこれから実践してみようではないかという努力
精進だと説明はあるんです
それでこちらの説明は何でしょうかと
今私がした説明っていうのは
なんとなくやる気が出てくるだけのことなんです
やっぱりそれ説明はそれでもぴったし合うんです
だからこちらはまあ中途半端でサティをやったところで
これぐらいわかったんだから中途半端だとあなです
もっと真剣にサティを完成してやらなくちゃいけないって同じことなんです
だから今はサティあるんだから
これぐらい見えたんだ
でもサティはガタガタ状態で弱くて中途半端なサティで気づいたり気づかなかったりとかね
いろいろあります そんなことではできてよくないんだと
サティはもう日夜時間のあるように
徹底的に完成するまでやらなくちゃいけないというふうに思うんですね
その思うことは  ミリーサンボッチャンですね
それでサティを頑張ってみようと思ったところで
なかなかうまくいかないとかね
眠たくなるとかね やけにいっぱい食べたくなるとかね
誰かと喋りたくなるとかね
出てくるんですね で 本当にサティが実践した人は自然に喋れなくなるんだけど
で まあ瞑想して ただちょっと合間が出たらものすごい大きい声で喋るということは
また まあそれはヴィパッサナーとは言えないんですね
で とにかく 例えばサティをやりたい
実践したいんだけど なかなかうまくいかない
もう喋りたくてしょうがなくなる
食べたくてしょうがなくなる
眠たくてしょうがなくなる
瞑想時間が終わっちゃったら
すぐほっとして で もう隣の人といきなり世間話始まるとかね
そういうふうな現象が出てくる
そうすると あ 精進しなくちゃいけない
これは自分がもうサティを実践するんじゃなく
自分持っていた不善をまた磨いてやろうではないか
もう修行中でなかなか手入れできなかったんだと
不善の手入れ そういうことなんです
突然家のこと心配だから
私は早く帰りますと 二日瞑想しようと来た人が一日で帰るとかね
やっぱり家のこと心配だ
そういうふうな この  とにかくしないほどのバカバカらしいことをしちゃうんですね
その心配してうちに戻る人々が家を一日も空けたことはないんですかと聞きたくはなるんだけど
そんなこと言ったら私はどうせもう批判されているもんだからね
やっぱりもうさらに敵を作ること必要ないってことで
はい わかりました どうそうと言うんです
平気で一週間でも自分が家を出て
いろんなこういういろんなことをやってる人々なんです
そうすると二日瞑想に来たら
まあ１日目にやっぱりやりそこなかった仕事をちょっとやりますよとかね
それやらなくちゃと やっぱり家のこと心配だ
来るのはおばあちゃんなんですけど
やっぱり子供のこと心配やと
そういうもう全くの嘘を言って
もう本人はわからない
自分が言ってるのは嘘やと
もう犬にも猫にも負けてるっていうこと
本人が全くわからないんだけど
すっごい理屈的に言うんですね
だからそれに反対しちゃったらすごく怒るんですね
二度とこの坊主の顔を見ないんだと
ですから まあはい どうそうと言っちゃう以外もないんですね
だから結局ことは同じことなんですね
できない人にはできないと
阿呆は阿呆や だから阿呆と言うようになる
これ戦争に出て戦うことやとお修行っていうのは
お釈迦様例えているのは
じゃあ遊びで言っているわけじゃないんです
単なる文学的なことを言いたくて言ってるわけじゃなくて
そういうの通りだから
根性弱いんだったら全くできないんです
だからわずかでも苦行させてないでしょうに
それよりはこのスポーツやらね
まあやる どれほど苦行しているんですかね
エアロビクスやったりとか
ダンスやったりする人々がね
体も弱いなのに 社交ダンスやらあだこだとかね
あのどうでしたっけ？千駄ヶ谷でもね
私の瞑想会やるその日はなんかダンスか見た
あの先生とよく話していると
踊れる人踊れるか 先生は上手ですけど
体を動かすのはこっちこっち
もう大変 でもだからそれをやっている
本当は苦行なんですね
その人々にとって それでもやってますし
ですから お釈迦様はこれは戦争に戦うぐらいの難しいことと言ったってのは
わずかでも苦行はないんだからね
誰にでもできるはずなんですね
で それでもあのやっぱり消えない場合はね
なかなかやる気は出てこない
とにかくこの精進というのはそういうところで働くんであって
分別能力ついてくると
もうそれで満足しないで
さらにさらにサティを完成しようと
サティを完成すれば何を見えるだろうかということで精進するんです
で 自然に精進が生まれるならば
その人は好いている なんのことなく
今は感じることは違うんだと
今はまた違うんだというと
なんとなく気持ちが興味が出てきて
やる気が出てくると それで食べるものもやっぱり時間の無駄だと
人と喋るのも挨拶するのも時間の無駄だからという感じで
自分だけの世界に入って
とにかくとにかくサティを実践してみるとかね
これこの自然に生まれてくるならばありがたいことで
自然に生まれてこないならば
まあわざと精進しなくちゃいけない
それで同じことでピーティが生まれてくるんですね
ピーティサンボッジャヤが次に生まれてくる
ピーティっていうのは
このまあ喜と書いてますから喜びなんですね
ヴィリヤばっかりやってると気持ち悪くなっちゃうんですね
一生懸命頑張るとまあ疲れてしまって
でもそういうのは正しい努力じゃないんです
努力したところですごく気持ち悪くなったと
やる気がなくなったと
世の中でごく普通にあるでしょ
もうなんとかにものすごい努力する
励む それで疲れたと いつ終わるんですかと
こんなものはとかね 正しい努力じゃないんです
例えば子育てにヒステリーを起こすという場合は
それはやり過ぎなんですね
母親が だって自然的に考えたら
どう考えたっても子育てでヒステリー起こすわけないはずでしょうし
そんなに自然的に子育てでヒステリー起こすんだったら
このね まあ死産というかね
そんなもう繋げていくわけじゃないし
どこかでおかしくなっちゃうんです
それ人間だけの現象だから
動物も自分の子供を食べたり殺したりする場合ありますけど
それはもう自然の法則にのっとって
あの 例えばもう 100匹ぐらいワニを産んでしまっちゃったら
そのワニたちがみんな食べられなくて
一人も残らず死んじゃうんですね
だからやっぱりほとんど死んで 1
匹  2匹しか残らないようにはなってるんです
それは子育てではワニのお母さんがヒステリーを起こしてるんだっていうことではないんです
で 例えば子育てにわかりやすい例ですから言いますけど
どこかで母親がやり方まずいと
あるいはやり過ぎとかね
何か自分の考え方あって
それによってもうこういう風にやるぞと思ったりしたりする
それで嫌がって疲れるというならば
それは正しい努力じゃないんです
勉強したところで疲れたと嫌になったというならば
その人の努力は間違ってるんですね
だからただ頑張るぞ ただ頑張るぞではなくてね
まあそこら辺ちゃんと気をつけて考えなくちゃいけないんです
本当の努力だったらいつでも喜びで終わるはずなんです
正しい努力っていうのは喜びで終わるんです
どうだ やったぞという感じで終わっちゃうんです
だからお釈迦様は 4番目にちゃんとピーティ書いてるわけです
人が精進するかもしれませんだけど
それによってピーティが喜びが生まれてこなきゃ要注意と
悟りの方向じゃ方向じゃないんです
間違った努力は当然間違ってる結果出すんです
正しい努力しか正しい結果出しませんから
だからヴィリヤ精進の次
喜 昇覚支が出ているんです
だからこういうリストのこの重大性というのはそういうことなんだから
順番さえもすごく大事なんです
だからダブルのことはもう当然知っていたんです
サティっていうのは あっちこっちで 37の中でいろんなところで言ってるんだから
そういうことよりは やっぱりこのすごく気をつけて実践修行のことを考えて言ってるんですね
だから精進しましょうと言ったっても
やたらに精進ではなくて
やっぱり精進することによって本当に喜びが生まれてくるかないかということの問題なんです
そこで物事を分別して見えてくる人がさらに見ようとする
さらに見ようとすると
その当然さらに見えてくる
それでさらに分別能力が出てくる
じゃあ新しい発見が出てくる
新しい発見が出てくると
何が結果として生まれるんですかね
感情としては 喜びが当然生まれてきます
その喜び一つ いわゆる見えてきたんだから
まあまあそこまでわかったという喜び
で それだけではないんです
このヴィパッサナーに必要な喜びっていうのは
で 心はずっと修行して清らかな方向へ持っていくと
この貪瞋痴やら妄想やら妄想というのはほとんど無知のことを働きながら
そういうのはもう機能しなくなるんですね
もう入る余地がなくなっちゃう
真剣にサティをすると妄想する暇がないんです
忙しくて で そこで心が長い間清らかに回転しているんだから
すごい純粋に すごい純粋じゃなくて完全な純粋な方向回転しているんだから
結果として心もすごい喜びを感じる
体でも喜びを感じる 自分の意志とは関係ないんです
なんで喜んでるかという本人もわからないんです
ただ喜びを感じる で 一生懸命頑張っている
で サティが実現している
それからいろいろ妄想やらいろんな余計なことやら
もう入る余地がなくなって
で まあ仮にその人にとっては別に人ともう楽しく喋る暇もない
美味しいご飯あっちこっち取って取って食べようとその喜びもない
ほとんど楽しみが消えてるんです
もう寝ようと思って寝るのもったいないと思ったりして
また修行ばっかりしたりして
で 苦しいはずなんですけど
すごく楽しい 笑いたいほど楽しくなっちゃう
その楽しみが この俗世間から違う道
出世間の道に入っている時
確実に生まれるものなんです
それはもう日本ではね
私にわかりやすい例えは思い浮かばないんだけど
例えば自分がもう山の上とかね
すごい高いところに家を建てて中にいると
すごい雨が降って 下は洪水にもう流れ流されているんだ
すごい勢いで 自分がいるところには絶対水が入ってこない
見ているとそんな感じなんですね
自分が離れているんだと
ですから 俗世間の苦しみの流れから心が離れてて
ヴィパッサナーのサティの実践に入っちゃうと
そういう世の中の苦しみをちょんちょんと頭に浮かんだっても
なんか自分がその世界に今入ってないんだから
今離れてるんだからってことで喜びが生まれてきます
すごい強烈な喜びなんですけど
喜びが生まれてくるとまたやる気が出ていく
また精進しやすくなる
精進するとまた分別能力が進んでいく
そうするとさらにサティを実践しなくちゃいけない
本当はこのリストの順番でいつでも見てください
この これからこう来てと
こうやってつなげていることと
また逆にもこうなってるんですね
でもそこでここに止まっちゃうんです
あの分別能力があるんだから
サティが成長するってことはならないんです
それで終わっちゃう サティがあると分別能力が生まれて
分別能力があると努力したくなる
努力すると喜びが生まれてくる
喜びが生まれてくると努力したくなる
努力したくなると さらに努力すると分別能力が生まれてくる
分別能力が生まれてくるんだから
やっぱりもうさらにサティっていうことは自然につなげてない
本人がやらなくちゃいけない
だからサティは土台なんです
だから仏道はやっぱりサティで始まるんです
それは本人の意思でやらなくちゃいけない部分
それは我々の宿題であって
それを宿題ちゃんとやると
他のものはきれいに自然に揃ってくる
努力しなくて それで悩まなくてもいいんです
自動的にサティも発達してくるということは絶対ない
サティは自動的に でも喜びは自動的に
次に パスサッディ パスサッディっていうのはその享安か慶安とかでしたっけ？どちらは
享安というね で 軽い安らぎではなくて
軽さと安らぎっていう意味なんです
軽く安らぎが生まれるっていう意味じゃないんです
ですから 享安という意味はあまりちょっとピンとこない感じなんですけど
パスサッディ パスラッディっていうのはすごく落ち着くという意味なんです
ものすごく落ち着いてくるんです
歩く時も喋る時も すごく落ち着いて
焦らない 焦りが消える状態ですね
体の中でも心の中でも
この焦りっていうことはもう消えてしまう
ちゃんと着々と順番で行動する
ですから 焦りが消える状態
すごい徹底して落ち着いた状態ということで理解すればいいんです
そこでこの人が努力する時は落ち着いてないかもしれませんし
喜びが生まれてくることも落ち着いてないかもしれませんし
そこで自然に落ち着いてくるんですね
道がこうやって頑張ってくると
物事見えてくると 無意味ではないんだと
この方でやればよろしいということで
精神的に落ち着いてきます
で この心が落ち着いてくるんだから
それまた修行は長い間
何年もやってる人ですからね
例えばヴィパッサナーのレベルに入ってる人だったら
ですから その人は長い間修行してきたんだから
体も本当にすごく軽く感じる
柔軟性があるように感じる
あっち痛いとかこっち痛いとかね
あることなくなって すごく柔軟性
心もすごく柔軟性が持つようになる
時々体も体ものすごい軽いんだと
本当に軽いんだと 体重はないんだと
と感じるんですね だから人の欲と怒りがあればあるほど体が重いんです
歩く時に 例えばもう怠け者だったら
階段見たら あー嫌だ 階段だと思っちゃうでしょう
そこでよっこらしょと言って登らなくちゃいけない
それで膝が痛いし 腰が痛い
あるいは あれ子供だったら
なんも階段大丈夫 どんどんどんどん上がっ--